parce que tout le monde allume sa bouilloire
au même moment.
(Rires)
1,5 million de bouilloires, c'est un problème sérieux.
Donc imaginez que vous créiez des bouilloires,
et que vous ayez trouvé un moyen de résoudre ces échecs du système,
parce que c'est une pression énorme
sur le système,
simplement parce que le produit n'a pas pensé aux problèmes
auxquels il allait devoir faire face une fois dans le monde.
J'ai regardé plusieurs modèles de bouilloires sur le marché,
et observé la ligne de remplissage minimum,
cette information qui vous donne
la quantité que vous devez mettre dans la bouilloire,
et elle est entre deux et cinq tasses et demi d'eau
pour faire simplement une tasse de thé.
Voici une bouilloire, par exemple,
qui a en fait deux réservoirs.
L'un est une chambre d’ébullition, l'autre est le réservoir d'eau.
L'utilisateur doit pousser sur ce bouton
pour faire bouillir son eau,
ce qui veut dire, parce qu'on est tous fainéants,
que vous remplissez seulement ce dont vous avec besoin.
C'est un produit qui engendre des changements de comportements :
un produit, un système ou un service
qui intervient et résout ces problèmes en amont.
Bon, nous sommes dans une arène technologie,
donc ces objets sont très populaires,
mais si nous devons continuer
à créer, acheter, utiliser et jeter
ces produits aussi vite que nous le faisons,
c'est-à-dire à la vitesse de la lumière...
Il y a 7 milliards d'habitants sur la Terre,
il y a 6 milliards d'abonnements pour des téléphones portables
en date de l'année dernière.
Chaque année, 1,5 milliard de téléphones sont produits dans le monde
et certaines entreprises disent que leur taux de production
est plus élevé que le taux de natalité dans le monde.
152 millions de téléphones ont été jetés l'année dernière aux États-Unis
dont seuls 11 % ont été recyclés.
Je suis Australienne. Nous avons 22 millions d'habitants et -- ne rigolez pas --
il se dit qu'il y a 22 millions de téléphones
dans les tiroirs des gens.
Il faut que nous trouvions des façons de résoudre ces problèmes,
parce que ces choses-là sont compliquées.
Il y a tellement de choses à l'intérieur de ces produits.
De l'or ! Saviez-vous que c'est aujourd'hui moins cher
d'avoir de l'or d'une tonne de vieux téléphones portables
que d'une tonne de minerai d'or ?
Il y a beaucoup de matériaux complexes et précieux dans ces produits,
donc nous devons trouver des façons d'encourager leurs désassemblages,
pour ne pas que ça arrive.
Voici une communauté au Ghana,
et les déchets électroniques
sont considérés par les Nations Unies
comme représentant un trafic de 50 millions de tonnes.
C'est comme ça qu'ils récupèrent l'or
et d'autres matériaux de valeur.
Ils brûlent les déchets électroniques en plein air.
Ce sont des lieux d'habitation, et on voit ça partout dans le monde.
Et parce qu'on ne voit pas les ramifications
de ces choix que nous faisons en tant que concepteurs,
qu'entrepreneurs, que consommateurs,
ces activités externes prennent places,
et touchent la vie de ces gens.
Nous devons donc trouver des solutions plus intelligentes,
novatrices, qui concernent le système,
si nous voulons vivre de manière plus durable dans ce monde.
Imaginez si, lorsque vous achetez votre téléphone portable,
un nouveau pour remplacer l'ancien --
après 15 à 18 mois, c'est la moyenne
à laquelle les gens remplacent leur téléphone --
si nous continuons comme ça
à remplacer nos téléphones, nous devrions
trouver des façons de boucler la boucle de ces systèmes.
Les gens qui produisent ces téléphones,
et je suis sure que certains sont ici,
pourraient faire quelque chose qui s'appelle un système à circuit fermé,
ou un service pour système de produits,
en identifiant qu'il y a une demande du marché
et que cette demande ne va pas s'en aller,
vous créez le produit pour résoudre le problème.
Créer pour le désassemblage, pour la légèreté.
On sait que certaines de ces stratégies
sont utilisées pour les voitures Tesla.
Ce genre d'approches n'est vraiment pas compliqué,
mais comprendre le système
et chercher des alternatives viables, adaptées au marché et
répondent aux attentes des consommateurs
nous permettra d'enfin changer de manière radicale
la voie sur la durabilité.
Parce que je dois vous dire que
la consommation est le principal problème.
Mais la conception, le design est une des meilleures solutions.
Ces produits sont partout.
En identifiant des façons alternatives de faire les choses,
on peut commencer à innover,
et je dis bien « commencer à innover ».
Je suis sure que tout le monde ici est innovant.
Mais pour utiliser la durabilité
en tant que paramètre, que critère
pour créer des solutions basées sur le système,
parce que comme je viens de le démontrer avec ces produits simples,
ils sont en partie responsables de ces énormes problèmes.
Nous devons regarder la vie entière
des choses que nous faisons.
Si vous n'avez que le papier ou le plastique --
oui le ré-utilisable est bien mieux --
et le papier est pire,
et le papier est pire parce qu'il pèse
entre 4 et 10 fois plus que le plastique,
et lorsque nous comparons, d'un point de vue des cycles de vie,
un kilo de plastique et un kilo de papier,
le papier est bien mieux,
mais la fonctionnalité d'un sac plastique ou d'un sac papier
pour porter vos courses jusque chez vous n'est pas faite avec un kilo de matériau.
C'est fait avec une toute petite quantité de plastique
et beaucoup plus de papier.
Parce que la fonctionnalité est ce qui définit l'impact environnemental,
Et je vous disais que les concepteurs me demandent des matériaux écologiques.
Je réponds qu'il n'y a que quelques matériaux qu'il faut éviter à tout prix.
Pour les autres, tout dépend de l'utilisation,
et tout ce que nous créons et produisons dans notre économie
ou achetons en tant que consommateurs est fait pour une certaine utilisation.
Nous voulons quelque chose, donc nous l'achetons.
Nous devons donc trouver des solutions
intelligentes, élégantes et sophistiquées
qui tiennent compte du système en entier
et de la vie entière des objets,
en partant de l'extraction jusqu'à la fin de leur vie,
ainsi nous pourrons commencer à trouver de vrais solutions innovantes.
Une dernière chose avant de vous laisser,
Je parlais avec un concepteur important avec qui je travaille et je lui demandais,
« Comment ça se fait que vous ne travailliez pas sur la durabilité ? »
Il m'a répondu : « J'ai présenté un projet durable à un client récemment,
il s'est tourné vers moi et m'a dit,
« Je sais que ça va couter moins cher,
je sais que ça se vendra mieux,
mais nous ne sommes pas des pionniers, parce qu'ils se font tirer dans le dos. »
Je sais que vous êtes tous ici des pionniers et j'espère
qu'il y en a plein d'autres dans le monde car nous devons résoudre ces problèmes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)